Hi, I'm Jeff Stumb, director of The
Great Race, and we're making this
series of instructional videos to
help newcomers,
first-time participants, and
people returning to The Great Race,
maybe for the second time.  We're going to talk
about clocks, chronometers, and
wristwatches, because in this event, the
important thing is to start on time,
stay the course, and stay on time
.  And you can do it with these pieces.
This is the 9-inch watch that
most runners will use.
It is made by Sawtooth Clocks.  It has
a very consistent second hand.  But it
has a rather loose minute hand and it's
quite easy to make a 1
minute mistake with the clock.  When I run, I
no longer use a watch.  Some people use
the watch only for the second hand, to
see the seconds pass, but they don't
use it to see the time of day.
Now, you can use a
digital stopwatch like this one.  Most of these
stopwatches have three buttons on
top and are designed so you can
toggle between the time of day and
stopwatch mode.  And if you set up this
stopwatch correctly, you won't
need that watch.  You can take it
with you if you want and use it in
emergencies, knowing that the minute hand
could easily come off.  Or,
as time approaches the
top of the hour, when the
second hand is in the 55 or 56
second range, moving towards zero at
the top of the clock, the
minute hand has already moved to the next
minute, and it can be problematic
to figure out what minute it actually is.
But the stopwatch allows you to start
and stop the timer for many
maneuvers; many maneuvers in this
race will require the stopwatch to make you
perform a specific maneuver
for 25 seconds, maybe a minute
and a half, maybe 6 or 7 minutes.  The
stopwatch is excellent for that.
You will change the speed and it will tell you to
go from 30 to 35 for 7 minutes
and 30 seconds.  At the end of that
time period, go to 45. You start the
stopwatch and 7 and a half minutes
later you can stop it and move on to the
next prescribed speed.
You can also change the time of day.
You will use the time of day from the
stopwatch, clock, or
wristwatch at the start, in transit, or upon
resumption after lunch.
Therefore, you need to know how
to use the stopwatch or clock to
make sure you have the
correct time.  The third watch you can
use is a wristwatch.  However
, it must be analog, without a
stopwatch mode.  So, how do
I set up these clocks?  Every morning,
at the official start, there will be an
official clock that shows the exact time of the
day and you can reset all your
watches.  And you'll probably have to
restart them 24 hours after
the previous day.  You can also
call WWV, and that number will be
provided to you during the Great Race.